ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola soy daniela fraga y soy lesbiana y
no es que esté saliendo del closet aquí
frente a todos ustedes no se angustien
ya lo hice hace 8 años pero si es la
primera vez que lo digo con esa palabra
que a mí me parece muy fuerte y para
hacerles y para poner el ejemplo quiero
que hagan un ejercicio conmigo quiero
que levante la mano quien de aquí se
siente cómodo diciendo ahí va una pareja
de gays
ya muchos no porque la palabra que ella
está dentro de nuestro campo léxico
diario ahora quiero que me digan quién
de ustedes se siente igual de cómodo
diciendo ahí va una pareja de lesbianas
veo menos manos la realidad es que ni
siquiera yo me siento cómoda diciendo la
palabra lesbiana sino que es una palabra
super fuerte y que incluso a veces puede
ser hasta confundirse con alguna ofensa
no como como cuando le decían a nuestros
primitos a nuestros hermanitos amiguitos
de la escuela pegas como niña pateas
como niña corres como niña como si hacer
las cosas como niña estuviera mal o
fuera menos pero hoy muchas mujeres muy
valientes nos han enseñado que sé que
podemos pegar y que podemos pegar muy
duro en 1915 ninguna mujer podía votar
en ningún país hoy 104 años después 10
países están siendo gobernados por
mujeres pero tras eso no es lo
importante lo importante es que según
estadísticas faltan 107 años para que
haya variedad de género en los gobiernos
de los países o sea falta un chingo
entonces estas mujeres nos han enseñado
que podemos ser muy valientes así como
ha habido muchas mujeres valientes que
me han hecho poder salir aquí y decirles
que soy lesbiana salí del clóset hace
ocho años cinco de esos años fueron los
peores para mí para mi familia para mi
pareja los peores pero hoy estoy segura
de que si no hubiera hecho ese pequeño
acto de valentía que tuve a los 19 años
para decirles que me gustaban las
mujeres hoy no sería ni la mitad de
feliz ni la mitad de libre ni estaría
tan cerca de lo que estoy de mi familia
aunque si hubo una regla muy clara mi
mamá me dijo por favor daniela no vayas
por el mundo gritando que eres lesbiana
así que mamá si eventualmente vez esto
en youtube pues ya rompí la regla
pero pero es eso a final de cuentas hay
muchas condiciones que nos obligan a ser
valientes no la valentía no es algo que
salga porque queramos o porque decidamos
hoy voy a ser valiente son las
condiciones que estás viviendo lo que
marcan esa necesidad de ser valiente
por ejemplo yo fui valiente cuando salí
del clóset mi papá no está en ustedes
para saberlo ni yo para contarlo pero mi
papá fue sacerdote de la iglesia
católica a 10 años de su vida
y después él es un hippie empedernido y
nunca estuvo de acuerdo en la relación
que había iglesia-estado y se salió dijo
de aquí no puedo hacer yo mi chamba me
voy a otro lado después se conoció con
mi mamá mi mamá es de un pueblo de
michoacán que se llama tacámbaro así que
se imaginarán que no es la más de mente
abierta que existe
entonces pues mi condición en ese
momento fue súper difícil la condición
que me puso ahí para salir del closet y
que todo valiera madre cinco años fue
porque tenía una condición muy difícil
que enfrentar en casa hoy a las mujeres
nos están matando y esa es otra
condición súper difícil en lo que va en
el año ha habido 638 feminicidios y hay
más de 125.000 víctimas de violencia son
cantidades súper grandes y hace poco
salieron las mujeres a la ciudad a las
calles de la ciudad de mexico a marchar
por nuestra seguridad y la realidad es
que no justifico los actos que pasaron
en el ángel de la independencia pero se
los agradezco porque creo que son cosas
que se necesitan hacer los grandes
cambios no van con cosas tranquilas y
que pasa pues la verdad es que si me
pongo en los zapatos de ella y platico y
practico la empatía puede entender por
qué es por lo que están luchando puedo
entender que hoy ellas no están luchando
por ellas sino que
están luchando por mí yo no soy no no
soy activista en este tipo de marcha sin
embargo estoy profundamente agradecida y
sé que todavía les falta muchísimo
tiempo para que sigan respetando mis
derechos cuando logramos ponernos en los
zapatos del otro no sabemos más bien
podemos comprender por qué está luchando
independientemente de si estamos en esa
lucha no estamos en esa lucha pero antes
de seguir quiero dejar bien claro en la
palabra valentía a qué me refiero cuando
hablo de valentía la valentía es aquella
virtud del ser humano que lo impulsa a
hacer cosas a pesar del miedo de los
retos o de los riesgos que haya que
pasar
y esta parte importante es la última
parte es a pesar de los riesgos y a
pesar de los riesgos que haya que
sobrepasar eso es lo que hace un acto de
valentía pero quién puede ser valiente
si no tiene un sueño una meta algo por
qué luchar nadie si no sabes a dónde
quieres llegar no sabes cuál es el
camino que quieres recorrer entonces a
final de cuentas cuando logramos tener
eso bien claro vamos a estar motivados a
poder salir adelante y para esto les voy
a platicar desde mi otra área de
expertise ya vieron que la primera es la
homosexualidad la segunda es la el
marketing y la innovación
entonces desde esta parte quiero
contarles llevo tres años trabajando en
una empresa que se llama blue box lo que
hacemos en blue box es unir grandes
corporativos líderes de sus industrias
que tienen retos de procesos mercados
logística ingredientes etcétera con
emprendedores que tengan la solución o
que puedan aportarles en esto de esta
manera el corporativo crece de manera
mucho más rápida o resuelve sus
problemas de manera mucho más rápida y a
menor costo el emprendedor crece de
manera exponencial a tener estos
corporativos como clientes y blue box es
el que se encarga de que esta relación
sea una relación de éxito en estos tres
años he aprendido dos cosas bueno muchas
cosas pero dos cosas que aplican mucho
está esto de que les estoy hablando la
primera es la definición de problema
cuando le pregunto a alguien que es
problema la verdad es que me va a decir
un millón de cosas y nada como tan claro
para mí la mejor definición del problema
es
supongamos que esto es una gráfica es
este es el lugar en donde estoy y este
es el momento este es el lugar en donde
quiero estar todo esto que hay aquí es
un problema y un problema se reduce a
crisis y caos dos lados hay crisis y
caos cuando se presenta un problema la
otra cosa que aprendí es que cuando hay
una empresa que está pasando por una
crisis es muy probable que haya muchas
otras empresas que van a pasar la misma
crisis crisis tarde o temprano y son
aquellas marcas o aquellas empresas que
se dedican y que se enfocan en innovar
las que logran hacer cosas distintas y
logran salirse del status quo y a final
de cuentas pueden poner una algo extra
en el mercado y quedarse en la mente del
cliente
eventualmente la competencia se va a dar
cuenta que a ellos les fue bien
empezarán a hacer las cosas igual que
ellos y ya no dejará de ser una
innovación y se convertirá en el estado
común de las cosas pero eso pasa con las
empresas y pasa con nosotros pasa porque
para nosotros cuando estamos dentro de
de nuestra burbuja no no tenemos nada
que hacer estamos cómodos nos gusta el
lugar en donde estamos estamos
tranquilos pero en cuanto llega alguien
y te traen a esa burbuja o te saca de su
zona de tu zona de confort ahí es donde
hay donde se nos mueve el tapete y ahí
ya no sabemos qué hacer ahí surge la
necesidad de ser valiente saben porque
méxico está dentro del top 25 los países
más felices del mundo porque estamos en
el número 23 y volteamos a todos lados y
parece que nos está cargando la fregada
porque estamos en ese lugar pues estaba
un poco de la mano con lo que les decía
de los sueños y el propósito para
nosotros los mexicanos y en general para
los latinoamericanos el sueño y el
propósito va mucho más allá de la fama
el dinero la belleza y tenemos un poco
más a que nuestros sueños metas o
aspiraciones vayan con la familia con
los amigos etcétera entonces cuando un
mexicano tiene un problema se estresa se
estresa y liberamos una sustancia que se
llama cortisol el cortisol baile toca la
puerta a la oxitocina y le dice oye
necesito ahora a mis amigos ya mi
familia cuando vemos a nuestros amigos y
familia nuestros niveles de cortisol se
bajan nuestro estrés se reduce se regula
se suelta cnop y ácido si somos
sumamente feliz pero el problema es que
el 75% de los mexicanos vivimos en un
estado de estrés diario entonces
soltamos una sustancia que se llama
cortisol que baile toca la puerta la
oxitocina y le dice oye quiero ver a mi
familia ya mis amigos los ves se reducen
los niveles de cortisol llegas se reduce
el estrés
genera zoppi ácidos y vuelves a hacer
sumamente feliz básicamente y en resumen
si a nosotros nos dan unos taquitos de
carne asada ya estamos a toda madre
pero tenemos que hacernos responsables
de esto no podemos estar el 75 por
ciento de nuestro tiempo el 75% de los
mexicanos no podemos estar estresados
siempre tenemos que encontrar eso que me
está estresando hoy y en donde yo no
estaría estresada para poder hacer algo
y lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
ser valientes y tomarnos esa
responsabilidad somos capaces de cambiar
nuestra realidad y no importa si son
actos de valentía pequeños o grandes no
importa si es salir de tu casa no
importa si es que no sea enfrentarse
contra muchísimas cosas pueden ser
acciones muy pequeñas pero haciéndolas
de una gran manera y les voy a poner
este ejemplo
19 de septiembre de 2017 7 millones de
personas en la ciudad de méxico salieron
a las calles por un macrosimulacro
sísmico que se viene haciendo desde el
temblor del 19 de septiembre de 1985 ay
me sigue pareciendo increíble que haya
sido el mismo día
salieron a la calle dos horas después
esos siete millones de personas y más
volvieron a salir a la calle por estamos
en una situación real a las 13 horas con
14 minutos méxico fue azotado por un
país por un sismo de 7.1 grados en la
escala de richter y generó caos en la
ciudad de méxico y en el país
en ese momento las oficinas de blue box
estaban a sólo una cuadra del ángel de
la independencia donde más se sintió una
de las zonas donde más se sintió el
temblor líneas caídas
ningún tipo de medio de comunicación y
todas las redes sociales inundadas como
con vídeos como los que están viendo
aquí atrás y una persona súper
importante para mí sin dar señales de
vida
seis horas después todo regresó a la
normalidad en cualquier otro lugar que
no fuera ciudad de mexico todos salimos
mandamos víveres hicimos muchas cosas
pero para ellos nada había vuelto a la
normalidad hubo gente que salió a la
calle a curar les el cuerpo a los
heridos a darles casa cama enchufes
redes de wifi todo eso pero no había
nadie que les curara el alma y esa fue
para mí la pregunta que detonó algo que
a veces puedo comparar un poco con con
un sentido de urgencia o ansiedad que no
me podía quedar parada en esa situación
sabía que estaba pasando algo pero no me
sentía parte de méjico y necesitaba
poder apoyarlos de alguna manera y así
surgió esta iniciativa que se llama este
puño se respeta este puño se respeta
consistía básicamente en imprimir muchas
hojitas con mensajes chingón es para los
mexicanos que pudieran curarles el alma
y muy padre y todo y llegaba y la
contaba y me decían no inventes a ni
cómo se te ocurrió es una súper buena
idea qué chingón y luego les le decía
bueno pues acompaña ánimo que yo me vaya
a la roma a pegar todos estos pues eran
algo imposible híjole es que hoy no
puedo es que mañana tengo un compromiso
es que hay para la próxima de verdad
espero que no haya una próxima
y eso fue lo que pasó ahí fue donde me
enfrenté al tercer reto de la valentía
es un zinc es un ciclo
el primero es encontrar ese motivo pues
eso ese problema por el que vas a ser
valiente que es lo que no te está
gustando hoy que lo quieres hacer el
segundo es encontrar esa acción que va a
cambiar el estado en donde estás hoy y
el estado donde vas a querer estar
mañana o en un tiempo y la tercera más
cabrona es ok ya decidí y pues me voy a
enfrentar a quien me diga que no iban a
ser muchísimas personas las que te digan
que no
11 valientes se aventaron y fueron
conmigo y esos 11 valientes estoy segura
de que hoy no viven no viven de la misma
manera en la que vivían antes de ese
terremoto eramos chavas de morelia y
gente de tijuana que también fue con
nosotros la ciudad de mexico y esas 11
personas se convirtieron en miles de
mexicanos poniendo estas cosas en redes
sociales y que al lunes siguiente
pudieron levantarse y salir de sus casas
listos para su siguiente acto de
valentía entonces la verdad es que las
etiquetas siempre van a existir como
dicen los memes te van a criticar por
todo así que tú haz lo que necesites
para cambiar tu situación importaciones
mujer homosexual negro judío niña niño
no importa cuál sea tu estado no importa
si llaman radical extremista romántico
las etiquetas siempre van a existir pero
sé valiente sé valiente y atrévete a
hacer las cosas porque para ser valiente
la realidad es que se siente chingón
cuando somos valientes lo hacemos porque
yo quiero cambiar mi estado de vida
porque yo quiero cambiar el lugar en
donde estoy pero si hacemos las cosas
bien no vamos a cambiar solo nuestro
lugar sino el de la gente que nos rodea
entonces la verdad es que así podemos
cambiarle la vida a la gente y a final
de cuentas es mejor arder que apagarse
lentamente es mejor salir y hacer las
cosas porque al final de cuentas
mientras hagas cosas buenas por las
razones correctas nunca te estarás
equivocando
muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]